ist doch röttger 49 größe 186 augen blau
grau haarfarbe dunkelblond gesamt
aussehens note auf einer skala von 1 bis
10 überlassen wir ihnen razzia holz kaum
steigen sie ein so wie wir präsentiert
auch autohäuser die personen in seinem
buch erhöht warum erstellen sie
steckbriefe für ihre figuren auf der
einen seite liefert das einfach geballte
information
wenn man sich nicht mehr genau erinnern
kann die vielleicht ein bestimmter
protagonist oder anderen figur aussieht
gleichzeitig war das bei uns früher mode
menschen zu kategorisieren und auch in
mit schulnoten zu bewerten dass
vielleicht nicht immer eine besonders
freundliche technik aber durchaus
aussagekräftig
wovon handelt alles sehen
alles sehen personen ganz bestimmte
stadt danach sehr verrückten stadt und
das buch begleitet diese person durch
einen tag und eine nacht
welche rolle spielt die stadt
b die hauptrolle sicherlich bin ich
beklage möglichen personen grieche
praktisch in deren köpfe hinein
aber diese personen wären nicht so wie
sie sind ohne die stadt das leben so
wenn diese wieder zurückgekommen sind
was bedeutet die soziologie im roman
eine ganz bestimmte soziologie die
motivation hintergrund manche der
protagonisten soziologie ist eigentlich
die königin der wissenschaft ich denke
dass ohne soziologie die allermeisten
phänomene die jungs umgeben die kleidung
der menschen pflegen der baustil der
häuser letztendlich die gestaltung der
umwelt selbst die natur ohne so züge
nicht wirklich erklärbar ist
wie viel autobiografisches steckt in
ihrem buch sehr viel mehr vieles gilt
bei manchen der protagonisten zum
beispiel ins taxi fahren
es geht um einen ehemaligen taxifahrer
montags unternehmer und ich war früher
in bielefeld taxifahrer nach taxifahrers
nacht hat sie verraten und sehr
interessante einblicke in das verhalten
und den alkoholgenuss vieler menschen
was leistet ihr roman man kann auf eine
angenehme und lustige art und weise
verstört werden in dem buch
hoffentlich und außerdem wir also ein
wirklich sehr guter witz wenn ich den
schweizer buchpreis gewinnen würde ein
witz bei dem wir gerne mit lachen
weiterhin gute fahrt
erhöht